[Música]
bienvenidos a en 5 minutos donde
intentamos explicar de manera sencilla
asuntos complicados el 25 de julio de
2022 los tunecinos fueron convocados a
las urnas para aprobar o rechazar una
nueva constitución propuesta por el
presidente hayes site una referendo
rechazado por la oposición y criticado
por organismos internacionales que contó
con muy poca participación en el que la
opción del sí se impuso con una mayoría
aplastante
porque el presidente decidió cambiar la
constitución cuáles son los principales
cambios a la carta magna y porque se
teme que túnez vuelva a caer en la
autocracia con la revolución de 2011
túnez encendió la mecha de lo que llegó
a conocerse como la primavera árabe una
serie de levantamientos populares en el
norte de áfrica y oriente medio en
contra de la pobreza y el autoritarismo
que provocaron entre 2011 y 2012 la
caída de varios líderes autocráticos
de hecho hasta hace poco tú eres era
considerado el único país de la región
en haber logrado mantener los logros de
la revolución y zin el abidín ben alí
fue derrocado tras 23 años en la
presidencia y el país se dotó de
herramientas para reestructurar tanto
sus libertades como su régimen político
la más importante de estas herramientas
fue la constitución de 2014 la nueva
carta magna tenía como objetivo
principal romper con el sistema
presidencialista y establecer un sistema
parlamentario entonces porque el actual
presidente decidió cambiarla en la
década que siguió a la revolución de
2011 el país no logró traducir los
alcances democráticos en progreso social
y túnez tuvo que hacer frente a
atentados terroristas como por ejemplo
los rain indicados por el estado
islámico en el museo del bardo en 2015
también al creciente desempleo y a los
escándalos de corrupción que erosionaron
la confianza en la clase política
principalmente en el partido conservador
islamista que tiene mayoría en el
parlamento desde hace 10 años y es la
principal fuerza política del país en
septiembre de 2019 túnez celebró
elecciones parlamentarias y
presidenciales el 14 de octubre del
mismo año países ayer un profesor
universitario que se presentó como
candidato independiente obtuvo una
victoria arrasadora y se convirtió en
presidente para muchos de sus votantes
saide representaba una solución a los
males de los que culpaban a la clase
política tradicional en 2021 el país ya
ha sumido en una enorme crisis económica
se vio aún más debilitado por la
pandemia de cody 19 y comenzó entonces
un período de intenso malestar social y
semanas de protestas un grupo
autodenominado un movimiento de 25 de
julio llamó a los tunecinos a salir a la
calle para pedir la intervención del
presidente y en la noche del 25 de julio
el día de la independencia ayer
destituyó al gobierno y anunció la
suspensión del parlamento
el partido islamo conservador en nada
denunció un golpe de estado y desde
entonces el presidente said se dedicó a
gobernar por decreto y terminó por
proponer una reescritura de la
constitución de 2014 cuáles son los
cambios más importantes y por qué desata
temores primero que todo país usaid
seleccionó el mismo a los miembros de la
comisión encargada de redactar el texto
según human rights watch trabajaron
durante cuatro semanas a puerta cerrada
y el texto final publicado por el
mandatario se alejaba de la propuesta
que se había preparado a diferencia de
la constitución de 2014 en la nueva
versión no menciona el estado civil que
garantizaba una relativa separación
religiosa en cambio afirma que túnez
forma parte de la comunidad islámica y
que el estado debe trabajar para
alcanzar los objetivos del islam esta
enmienda fue quizás una de las más
controvertidas los defensores de los
derechos humanos temen que pueda ser
utilizada para discriminar a otros
grupos religiosos
la nueva carta magna erosiona los
poderes del parlamento y de la rama
judicial que ya no se mencionan como
poderes sino como simples funciones los
jueces serán nombrados por orden
presidencial de hecho caisse side ya
había disuelto el anterior consejo
superior de la magistratura y despedido
a 57 jueces en los últimos meses
provocando manifestaciones en otras
palabras la constitución propuesta por
side concentra los poderes en la figura
del presidente por esta y otras razones
la oposición boicoteó el referendo poco
más de 30 por ciento del electorado voto
y en sí obtuvo el 94 6% de los votos hoy
los opositores al presidente y parte de
la comunidad internacional temen que el
paréntesis abierto por la primavera
tunecina haya terminado y el país caiga
de nuevo en la autocracia si les sirvió
este vídeo para entender el porqué del
cambio constitucional en túnez y sus
posibles consecuencias los esperamos en
otro episodio de 5 en france 24